I understand that people are yearning to
know how long this will all last and the
answer is entirely dependent on how much
people follow the rules on social
distancing following these rules is
mission critical if we're to protect the
NHS slow the spread and give the NHS
time to expand capacity and so to save
lives
the more people follow the rules then
the faster we will all be through it so
I say this to this small minority of
people who are breaking the rules or
pushing the boundaries you're risking
your own life and the lives of others
and you're making it harder for us all
we've included exercise as one of the
things that you can leave your house to
do because exercise is good for our
physical and our mental health but
please do not bend or break this rule we
can't rule out further steps but I don't
want anyone to think that any changes to
the social distancing rules are imminent
because the vast majority are following
the rules and to you to all those at
home to all those who are following the
rules I want to say thank you